[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
what we're going
to do in talking about social
preferences is the following.
We're going to start discussing
what our social preferences.
We're going to just
talk about what
do we think social
preferences are
and how do we think about
them, how do we measure them.
This is partially
what we did already
in class last week,
which gives you
some sense of some
ways of measuring them.
There are also other
ways of doing that.
We're going to discuss that.
We're going to
also discuss a bit
kind of like the
measurements that we
did in class that
seem sort of pretty
contrived in various ways.
Are they actually predictive
in some ways of real world
behavior that we care about?
Then we're going to
ask the question,
well, it seems like, from
measuring social preferences,
as we did in class, but also in
some experiments that we see,
it looks like
people are actually
quite nice to each other.
But we're going to
ask the question,
are people just genuinely
nice to each other?
Do they actually
care about others?
Or is it just
like, in some ways,
perhaps, social image or
other issues about like they
want to look nice
or they want to feel
good by being nice to
others or look like they're
nice to others, as opposed
to generally caring
about the well-being of others.
And we can talk through
some experiments
and some evidence that
lets us disentangle
between those kinds
of hypotheses--
are people genuinely nice or
are they sort of just trying
to look nice in various ways?
And then we're
going to talk a bit
about evidence towards the end.
This is the paper by
Gautam Rao and others,
which is the question about are
social preferences malleable
and can policies
change pro-sociality.
That is to say, can
we do certain things,
can we mix people in certain
ways-- it can be like this will
be how roommates are chosen,
and the specific people
we're going to talk
about is from India,
where poor students are
mixed with rich students.
And does that affect
how nice people
are, the rich students, in this
case, towards poor students,
but also towards other
people in general.
So are there some policies
that we can perhaps implement
that help people, society as
a whole, being more pro-social
and people being
nicer to each other
or doing things that
are good for the greater
good, if you want, overall.
As before, we're going to
look at two types of evidence.
We're going to look at lab
experiments and field evidence.
Lab experiments are the
types of experiments
that you saw so far.
And field evidence are sort
of the type of experiments
where we look at students being
mixed, rich and poor students.
What happens then to
people's social preferences
when you do that?
OK, so now let's sort
of back up a little
bit into review, very quickly,
of what we did last week.
I showed you sort of
an action, three games
to measure social preferences.
These are not randomly
selected games,
these are the most prevalent,
the most commonly-used games
in behavioral and
experimental economics,
which is the dictator game,
ultimatum game, and the trust
game.
You can read descriptions and
discussions of these games
in the background readings,
which is Camerer and Fehr 2004.
Now what are these games?
I'm going to briefly
review them right now.
And then I'm going
to go to the evidence
and go back to evidence that
actually uses these games.
So what are the
games, just to recap?
There's the dictator game,
which is very simple,
where the dictator gets some
money allocated to him or her.
And there's another person
who is the recipient.
And a dictator
just gets to choose
how much money does
he or she wants
to give to this other person.
That's it.
You can think of this as
some raw concern for others,
essentially to say, when
you don't know anything
about this other person--
often these games
are anonymous-- here's
an anonymous person whom
you could give some money.
And often it's another student.
It could be like a poor
person in Kenya or elsewhere.
Here's a person with
whom you don't have
any interactions whatsoever.
How much money do you
want for yourself?
How much money do you want
for this other person?
The original version
is just sort of 1 to 1.
Any dollar that you
give is given directly
to this other person.
There's different versions
where essentially any dollar is
converted, where essentially
the exchange rate is varied,
where it's cheaper
or more expensive,
if you give a dollar, the other
person gets $2.00 or $0.50
or the like.
OK, so that's the dictator game.
What's the ultimatum game?
It's sort of like a
bargaining game if you want.
It's sort of very, very simple
game theory if you want.
You can use that, which
is essentially used again
by experimental economists.
What they do is there's
two players again.
There's a proposer or the
sender that gives, again, like,
some divisible pie.
Think of this as
$10 or the like.
Often it's money.
And then you say a portion
of x is given, then,
to the responder.
The responder then
has the chance
to either accept or reject.
If the responder accepts,
then the division
is just implemented.
If the responder rejects,
then essentially both players
get nothing.
And why is it a game now?
Well, it's because
essentially the proposer
needs to sort of take
into account what
the other person is
going to do and have
some beliefs about that and
anticipating that, then sort
make that choice of how much
money would you like to give.
Finally, there's the
trust game, which
is, in fact, very
similar to the ultimatum
game except for that the
amount sent by the sender
is tripled before the
decider is supposed to say--
before they decide
how much to return,
the recipient decides how
much return, if anything.
So now essentially, it's like
a high-return opportunity
to give money, essentially
in a situation of high trust.
In particular,
there's communication.
If I'm playing with somebody,
I would tell that person,
yes, give me all of the money.
And if you are nice to
me, that money is tripled,
and I give you half of
it back, or the like.
So both of us are better off.
If there's lots of trust
between us, that's actually
implementable, and a sense
of, like, I'm telling you,
give me that money,
you'll give me that money,
and then I'm actually
returning that money.
But of course, if
there's no trust,
then that's what the game name
comes from, the trust game.
If there's no trust, I'm
going to tell you, give me
a bunch of money, you
might actually do that,
and then I'll just
keep it all for myself.
Or you might not even believe
me in the first place.
You might just say, yeah, I'd
love to, but I don't trust you,
Frank.
I give you nothing.
And then essentially,
nothing is tripled.
And that's meant to then measure
some form of trust in society
or that people have
with each other.
We're going to go
back to that in trying
to see what does it actually
measure in the real world.
So just sort of
having said that,
those are those
three things you saw.
And then there's
different versions
of these games that could
be sort of like-- you
can vary the privacy.
Are these games
private versus public?
Is it anonymous?
Do you know who the other
person is versus not?
Is there communication?
Can you talk to this
other person or not?
And what are the stakes?
Are we talking about
hypothetical choices?
Are we talking about money?
High stakes with money.
Are we talking about other
goods like apples or chocolate?
Any questions so far?
We'll get back to
the actual evidence,
but I should make sure
that these games are
clear to everyone.
That's sort of what
happened last time.
OK.
Now, backing up
a little bit now,
then the question is,
like, what is, in fact,
social preferences?
And so most economic
analysis in some way
assumes away social
preferences and sort of assumes
self-interest, very
narrowly defined.
And so that means that
people essentially only care
about their own interests
and their own outcomes,
and then the market is sort
of taking care of the rest.
And this is at the heart of
what Adam Smith originally
was saying, I think, in
The Wealth of Nations,
which is like, "It's not from
the benevolence of the butcher,
the brewer, or the baker
that we expect our dinner,
but from their regard
for their own interest.
We address ourselves
not to their humanity,
but to their self-love,
and never talk
to them of our necessity,
but of their advantage."
That is to say that when
everybody is very selfish
and cares about themselves,
just comparative advantage
and the ability to
trade with each other
will make sure that other
people do useful things for us.
So you can do the work
you do, make some money,
and then go to the bakery.
And the baker will give
you some bread in exchange
for some money, not because
the baker likes you or wants
to be friends with you or the
like, but because you pay them,
and it's in their
interest to give you
good bread because
you're going to pay them,
and you're going to come
back perhaps and buy
more bread in the future.
So that's sort of a pretty
reasonable assumption
in saying people are doing
useful things for each other
as part of a market transaction.
And that's what a
lot of economics
has assumed and done
for a long time.
Now, that is not
a bad assumption
at all in the sense
of, like, it's actually
pretty realistic in various
ways in thinking about humans.
The question is not
necessarily whether there
are some instances of whether
people care about others.
The question that we're
going to ask is, like, well,
what do we miss by ignoring
social preferences?
And so it's pretty
clear that preferences
depart from pure self-interest
in non-trivial ways.
And the question we're going
to ask is, like, are there
some concrete settings
where we really
care about this and
sort of say, well,
we should model
things differently?
And if we do that, we can
understand certain phenomena
better.
So the goal is
here to understand
how common and important
these departures are
and what their nature is, like,
how can we best model these.
And here's a nice example
of perhaps how one
might want to think
about social preferences
and how perhaps people think
about social preferences.
So this is a picture--
I don't know how well
you can see this--
taken in Hawaii,
which is a box where
banana bread is being sold.
It's freely available
to everybody,
so you can just take it.
I think there's some
price tag somewhere.
There's also a lockbox next to
it on the left of the picture
where you can deposit payments.
So the banana bread
costs some money.
You can deposit your payments.
There's nobody that
enforces it, but the lockbox
is such that it's
actually locked in a sense
that you can't
take away the box.
So when you see
that picture, what
perception of social preferences
or humanity does that reflect?
How do we think
about this picture?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That we're going to be
honest and give the money based
on how much [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So one assumption,
to some degree,
is, like, well, people seem
pretty nice in general.
It seems in a sense
of, like, we allow
them to just take
the banana bread
and run away and
not put in anything.
We sort of ask them nicely.
It costs, like, $1
or $5 or whatever.
Please put in the money.
It seems like the
conception to some degree
is, like, people are going
to be nice and just do that.
Is that all, or is
there something else?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
there's an expectation
not that everyone would
do the right thing,
but that the loss from
some people who would just
take the bread and run will be
maybe less than, for example,
the cost of labor or
staffing the booth.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Exactly.
So there's some--
the expectation,
to be more precise, is not
everybody is going to be nice,
but on average, most people
are going to be pretty nice
or adhering to this normal rule
that you should pay some money.
And some people might
run, but as you say,
it might not be worth standing
there in the heat all day
to make up for that.
Exactly.
And then what else is there?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: It gives
a perception of,
like, you don't expect
them to steal banana bread,
but you expect them to steal
the money, so you lock it.
PROFESSOR: Right,
there's a lock.
So it's like, in some
sense, you sort of think
that, on the one hand, the
assumption is most people are
going to be pretty nice.
But if we allow them to run
away with all the money,
at least there are some
people who, if allowed,
would not be nice at all.
In fact, they would take
away the money and not
only not pay for
the banana bread,
but also take away the lockbox.
So that's exactly what
I've written down here,
which is to say people in
general are nice enough.
Most will probably pay
for the banana bread,
so it's not worth sort of
standing around and ensuring
that.
But people also can be selfish.
At least, some people
will be quite selfish.
So if a lot of cash
were easy to take,
someone at least would take it.
Notice that's not an assumption
about everybody, or even
the majority.
It's just to say there's
a fraction of people
who, if given the opportunity,
might take away our money
and run from it.
So that's actually
a pretty good sort
of perspective for thinking
about social preferences, which
is to say that
self-interest is probably
a major driver of behavior
in many economic contexts.
In some situations,
self-interest is not
the main motive, in some sense.
Again, we don't need
to necessarily enforce
this for everybody.
People will be quite nice.
But there will be-- some
seemingly small departures
from pure self-interest
can dramatically
influence economic outcomes.
That is to say, if we
couldn't lock the box,
if you were not doing that,
somebody would take away
this box.
And now we couldn't offer
banana bread to anybody,
and the whole transaction
would go down.
Put differently, if we had
things like a theft or robbery
and so on, if there's
some people who are really
mean and essentially take
away all of our money,
now we can't do any transaction.
I can't have a shop trying
to sell stuff to people.
This is the examples [INAUDIBLE]
positive and negative.
Small things can actually make
huge differences for others.
This is like helping a
stranger with directions
or helping a stranger who
wants to go to the hospital
and so on.
That could make huge
differences in their lives,
even if the-- or calling an
ambulance for somebody, that
can make huge differences
people's lives,
even though the
action from your side
is actually relatively small.
Helping a fellow student
with computer trouble
or other issues that
they might have,
helping somebody who
is sad on a given day
feel better about themselves.
In fact, as you might
know, it's the Random Acts
of Kindness Week this week, so
doing random acts of kindness
might actually make a huge
difference in people's lives.
In fact, the problem
said, well, we'll
ask you to do some
of that, in fact.
Washing your hands is
particularly pertinent
right now.
Again, you might think you're
doing that to protect yourself,
and surely you are.
But in fact, there's also a huge
externality potentially that,
like, by protecting
yourself, you protect others
from potentially getting sick.
And that could make a huge
difference in people's lives.
Any questions on this?
OK.
So now we're getting back
to the ultimatum game.
I'm going to ask the question
about how are people actually
behaving in real situations.
How do people behave in general?
And perhaps, what
does game theory
say how people should behave?
How are people
behaving in reality,
and how does that compare to how
you guys behaved here in class?
So again, the ultimatum game,
you should be familiar with.
There's a proposer, a responder.
Proposer proposes
some split of the pie.
Responder can accept or reject.
Now, what does game theory
predict what people should do?
Like, in the absence
of social preferences?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
If you're the recipient,
you'll care only
about your own output
or your own outcomes.
Even if I offer
you $0.01 or $0.05
or whatever, whatever is
worth the transaction cost,
you're going to
accept everything.
So if I'm playing with you,
I'm going to anticipate--
I know that you will
accept essentially
any offer that's positive.
Even zero, you
might even accept,
because it's sort of
like, why do you care?
But you strictly prefer a
positive offer over no offer,
so you're going to accept that.
And then if I'm playing
with you, anticipating that,
I will just give you essentially
the lowest possible amount,
and that will be the outcomes.
Right?
So here it is.
The prediction is very clear.
The responder cares
only-- this is, again,
game theory, but game
theory in the absence
of social preferences.
I should be more precise.
So the responder cares
only about money,
so she will accept
any x that's smaller
than 0, any amount that's
given, because that's better
than not having any money.
The proposer will
understand that,
will only care
about money as well,
so offers as little as possible.
The proposer doesn't care about
how the recipient is doing.
So therefore, the
proposer will just
offer as little as possible
to maximize their own payout.
And then an equilibrium,
that will essentially
be the zero or smallest
possible offer will be made,
and that offer will be accepted.
So there will be no rejections,
either because, essentially,
there's no reason to
reject, and there will also
be no large offers of the
like because there's no reason
to give more than
minimal amounts.
OK.
So then what are typical
results in the ultimatum game?
What do people actually find?
Well, so most people offer
between 40% and 50% of the pie.
Such offers are mostly accepted.
The acceptance
rate is increasing
in the offer, which is to
say if you offer, like, 10%,
you have a pretty good
chance of being rejected.
If you offer, like,
30%, 40%, 50%,
you're much more
likely to be accepted.
And you offer, like,
70%, 80%, almost surely
you'll be accepted.
And an offer that's below
20% are mostly rejected.
Why is that?
Or what's the reason
for that, presumably?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
And why are you sort of upset
if somebody offers you 10%?
AUDIENCE: Because it shows
they're disrespecting you.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, something about
fairness or disrespect, or it's
just not a nice thing to do.
And now you'd rather
not have any money
or not take $1 or whatever
they offer to you.
You'd rather reject
that, so you're
willing to give up $1
to essentially get back
at the other person.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It could also
be that for some people,
the thought of settling for
such small amounts of money
is embarrassing, or it
feels like it's demeaning
or [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so
it's one of those.
Some of it is-- yeah, exactly--
I think, demeaning,
or just feels like--
so one way to put this is
you have inequality aversion
in some ways in the sense
of you just don't want to be
the person who has $1 when
the other person has 9,
or you don't want to have $0.10
when the other has, like, 9.90.
So you really don't like
inequality in some ways.
There are some versions of this
game where the computer sort
of allocates these choices.
And you can look
at how people are
rejecting those offers as well.
And they tend to not do
that, which sort of suggests
that it's really coming
from some sense of people
don't care so much about
the outcome, per se.
They care about the
fairness or the intention
of the other person.
But you're right.
There's other potential
considerations at play.
Now, what do things
look like in our class?
In fact, this looks
quite similar to what
people do in general.
I know you're very
special, but when
it comes to the
ultimatum game, you're
actually pretty ordinary.
So what you see is, essentially,
most people offer 40%, 50%.
Some people offer somewhat more.
You see in-- you can't
see this that well.
You see it in red
are the rejections.
So rejections tend to
be on the left side,
in particular when people
offer between 1% and 10%.
There seem to be around
some rejections, so 50%,
or maybe it's just below 50%.
But usually, if you look
at, essentially, about 50%,
or 40%, 50%, 60%, people tend
to not reject any offers.
Any questions on that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Could it
also be that people
are anticipating future games?
Or maybe not [INAUDIBLE],,
but sending a signal,
like there's any
similar [INAUDIBLE]
be better off [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes, that's
a great question.
So I kind of--
all of what I was
doing, and I should
emphasize this a bit more--
the way I implemented some
of these games in class,
some experimental economists
would get a heart attack
in terms of how sloppy that
was in a sense of, like,
a lot of these games, usually
when I show you these results,
these are usually very careful
games, where, essentially,
usually it's anonymous.
Usually it's a one-shot game.
Usually it's very clear
that it's a one-shot game.
You will just never
see that person.
You never even interact
with that person.
It'll be clear whether
it's public versus private,
and so on.
So usually in those games,
things are extremely clear.
There is no strategic
interactions, and so on.
All of these things are
essentially shut down.
And then you can look
at, randomly vary,
some of these characteristics
and look at deviations of that.
So you're right.
In our game, in fact,
you might sort of
think that, let's
just be nice now,
in part, because the
other person, maybe
I play with that person again.
And I wasn't really very
precise about that either.
I think actually they're
all like randomly allocated.
So in fact, that was
not a consideration,
but it wasn't entirely clear.
Or for example, some
people were selected,
and it happened to be that
it was 50/50 selection.
That may have affected others
in the class, and so on.
So a lot of these things
were fairly sloppy
in terms of the
actual implementation.
In the real games, that
would be all shut down
and done much more carefully.
There were some other
questions, I think?
No.
OK.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Was this
just for the chocolate?
PROFESSOR: I think this is--
I looked at all of these.
The ultimatum games all
looked very similar.
So this is, I think, for--
this is the money one.
But even for others, it
looked fairly similar.
I'll show you some
variation in the dictator
game in a second, where we have,
like, do the stakes matter?
Does it matter whether
it's private versus public?
it's chocolate or money?
And perhaps, why
might it matter?
We'll get back to
that in a second.
Turns out, it does matter.
I'll say a little bit
about that in a second.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So the
fraction of rejection
in the green [INAUDIBLE]
others, and then [INAUDIBLE]
is much higher.
The number of rejections
in, like, $1 to $10
much higher than [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] explain
the notion of fairness
or the equitable distribution
of the pie you just mentioned,
because [INAUDIBLE]
accept when they
are being given 90% of the
pie, whereas they are just not
ready to accept [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So that's a good point.
So you were saying
earlier, maybe some people
have some issues about inequity
or inequality across people.
So if that were the
only explanation,
then you would rejections
not only at, like,
if I give you $1, and I keep 9,
but also if they give you $9,
and I keep 1.
So that means there's
something else.
I think the fairness, people
don't object to inequality.
If I say, OK, I'll
give you a lot,
and you have more than I do,
people don't object to that.
People object to, if I keep a
lot and give you very little,
presumably because I'm selfish,
and I'm not nice to you.
So that's kind of the
sense of fairness.
So it's a fairness that
goes beyond the outcomes.
So we're going to
talk about this
for a bit, which is to say you
could just look at the outcomes
and say, how much is the
inequality of outcomes?
And I care about that.
But that doesn't
seem to be the case.
What seems to be
rather the case is
that people care
about intentions
one way or the other.
It's like, what was I thinking,
or was I a mean person when
I was doing this?
And if you get the sense
that I was not very nice,
you might reject almost
regardless of what
the outcome will be eventually.
And of course, you will
reject less if it's
more costly for you to do so.
But perhaps it's also the
case if I do, like, 70-30,
you might say, well,
that's maybe not nice,
but it's also not
that unfair either.
OK.
Right.
So now, one thing you can
ask is how do these games
look like across countries?
And as I said, this game
has been extensively played.
It's a game that like
lots and lots of people
have played in all
sorts of situations.
And the patterns are remarkably
stable across countries.
And this is also
the case-- like,
every time I play this
in class, these patterns
look exactly the same.
So whether people are
playing in Pittsburgh,
in Ljubljana, in Yogyakarta,
Tokyo, play all essentially
the same way.
And even increasing people's
stakes to, like, several months
pay by running
essentially the experiment
with poorer populations,
where you can pay,
essentially, days' or weeks'
or even a month's pay,
people seem to play very
similar across places?
Why is that?
It seems to be like
somehow rejecting
becomes a lot more
costly when I offer you,
like, a day's wage or the like.
But why do you think it
looks fairly similar as well?
Why do people still reject?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If your
goal is to get back
at the other person, if
the pool is just bigger,
then you're hurting them
more by denying them.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So it's exactly as you said.
There's two things going on.
On the one hand, rejection
becomes really expensive to me.
So if there's a month's wage,
and you give me 10% of that
and keep 90% of that, rejecting
10% off a month's wage,
that's three or four
days or whatever.
That's really
costly for me to do.
However, it's also really
mean of you to do that,
and I can really
screw you over now
by sort of rejecting that offer.
So those things essentially seem
to be more or less [INAUDIBLE]..
They go into
opposite directions.
Empirically it seems to be
that cancels each other out.
That's exactly right.
So now, there's a very
interesting paper then
that does this ultimatum game
in hunter-gatherer societies
and asks the question
about, like, while it
seems to be that
people behave fairly
similar in these games in
industrialized societies--
whether they're
relatively rich or not,
people seem to behave
very similarly.
But perhaps if you look at
hunter-gatherer society that
are quite different in
various ways, perhaps
there we can look at interesting
differences across places.
And so on the one
hand, we see there's
lots of uniformity of play.
In lots of places, people
seem to behave very similarly.
But there are some
important differences.
And perhaps what this line
of research is doing--
it's often called
cultural economics--
is to try to see what
is the role of culture.
And there's Nathan Nunn
and other people at Harvard
are doing this in particular,
inspired by Joe Henrich, who
is the leader of that, is
trying to look at, like,
what is the role of culture in
shaping people's preferences?
And so one thing they had
done-- and at the time,
they looked at 15 different
hunter-gatherer societies.
You can see them
here on the map.
Some of them are
in South America.
Some are in South America.
Some are in Africa.
And some are in Asia, Oceania.
And so you could look at
these different societies.
And by looking at the way
they are living and producing,
you can try to think about
potential predictions of how
they might behave and
social preferences behavior.
And there's two examples
here that we have.
One is the society that you
can see here, the Machiguenga,
which are, I guess, in--
which country is this?
AUDIENCE: Peru.
PROFESSOR: In Peru?
PROFESSOR: Who are in
Peru in Latin America.
You can see them.
They essentially are
independent families.
They do a lot of cash cropping.
Their way of living appears to
be slash-and-burn agriculture,
gathering food,
fishing, and hunting.
So it's overall-- and you can
correct me if that's wrong.
It seems to be fairly
individualistic in the sense
of the way people produce.
Essentially, they live
individualistically.
They are not really relying
on a lot of cooperation
in the way they produce
their food or their living.
In contrast, the
Lamaleras in Indonesia,
these are whale hunters.
Essentially, when you
try to hunt a whale--
I don't quite know.
I imagine, at least--
it requires lots of
cooperation in the sense of,
like, people have
to work together
by nature of essentially finding
food or hunting these whales.
And so they on a daily basis are
really relying on cooperation.
And so now this line of
research by Henrich and others
is trying to see, by looking
at people's way of living
and way of producing
on any given life,
is that predictive of people's
behavior in ultimatum games?
And what you see
is the following.
I'll just show you
what results are.
So the society in Peru,
the slash-and-burn
horticulturalists, seem
to have little concerns
for others outside of the
family or for social status.
What you see essentially
is relatively low offers.
Most of these offers
are being accepted.
There's essentially very
low rejection rates.
And that seems to
be essentially--
and the rejections of
amounts that are below 20%
is only, like, 1 out of 10.
So it seems to be the
case, this society
that looks a lot
more individualistic
is, in fact, much closer
to perhaps the assumption,
the neoclassical assumptions of
no social preferences mattering
in the sense of
they seem to be--
in the way, at least, they
play the ultimatum game,
they seem to be happy
to offer low amounts,
and they seem to also be not
upset or annoyed or getting
back to others who
offer them low amounts.
In contrast, if you
look at the Lamaleras,
the whale hunting culture based
on strong and meticulously
detailed corporation, what you
see is the mean offer is 57%,
or the mode is 50%.
There are quite
a few rejections,
in particular, rejections
of small amounts.
And that's to say, like,
there's really an expectation
of people cooperating.
And if you don't
cooperate, if you are not
playing by those
kinds of rules, people
are being punished accordingly.
And there are some others.
There's sort of another
culture of the Au/Gnau,
which is a culture where gift
giving is an avenue to status
and gives the right to ask
for reciprocity at any time.
So that's the thing that you
often see in India as well,
that people tend
to reject offers
that are very large
in part because they
think that's inappropriate.
They think that's just a weird
thing to do in a sense of,
like, I offer you,
like, 50% or 60%,
they just think, like, if
I accept this offer, now
I owe you something and
have to give you stuff back.
You are nodding.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yes.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
So that's in India as well
to some degree as far as--
yeah.
Any comments on this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Is that last
experiment anonymous?
Because if it's
anonymous, then there's
no sense of this specific
person [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: That's
a great question.
I think it may not have been.
I need to check.
I think-- so there's some
question on how closely in some
sense to the--
these are 15 societies.
So in some sense,
these are not strictly
speaking statistical
tests of, like,
does culture cause
this behavior?
Because you only have
essentially 15 observations
of certain ways people behave.
So in some sense, the mapping
between the description
of what I was telling
you, which surely
was inaccurate in terms
of how people really
live in those societies,
and their behavior
is more a descriptive mapping.
So in some ways, it could be
that even if it were anonymous,
people behave in certain
ways that reflects
a culture of cooperation is to
say, it's just inappropriate--
or reflect, essentially,
when they say,
if somebody gives you a
large amount or a large gift,
you're not supposed
to accept it.
You might sort of not accept
it even in an anonymous game
because you feel bad
about it afterwards
because you can't reciprocate,
if that makes sense.
But I have to look it up, what
the specific details were.
The paper is also-- and
it's a very short paper.
So it's also on the course
website if you want to look.
Any other comments?
Are you from Peru?
Do you know about the society?
Is that remotely accurate
what I was saying?
AUDIENCE: I'm not really sure.
PROFESSOR: All right, well,
you can look into this
and report back.
OK.
But anyway, it's a very
interesting application
of the ultimatum game because
it essentially tries to say,
we're trying to look
at how do people
relate in the real world.
And looking at these
different societies
gives you some
sense of, like, it
does seem to capture something
in the real world of how
people are, in fact, behaving.
OK.
So now we can sort
think about what's
going on in ultimatum games.
And we talked about
this a little bit,
but I want to be a
little bit more precise.
It's like, why do responders
reject low offers?
What's going on here?
What are people doing?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] spite.
PROFESSOR: Yes, and
so the spite is--
so what exactly are
you objecting to?
I asked this before,
but let me ask again.
AUDIENCE: So I think a lot of
things have already been said.
If you will reject, you
think it's unfair, so much so
that you would rather
that they get nothing,
you both get nothing,
than [INAUDIBLE]
take this pity offer.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So there's two things.
Let me put them out here.
There's two things here.
You're talking about the
second thing, I think,
which is the fairness part.
So one is about a procedural
thing, which is to say,
I object to procedure.
I object to you not treating
me nicely or fairly.
I'm just mad at
you for doing that.
Therefore, I reject.
Hypothesis number
one-- this is what
we were talking about
earlier, which is to say,
I just dislike being behind.
You offer me-- you keep 6.
I have 4.
I just don't like having
less than somebody else,
and I might reject that as well.
Can we disentangle
those explanations?
From dictator game data?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You can
have some [INAUDIBLE]..
I guess, reject [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So from the data
that I just showed,
or from the pure,
simple dictator game,
it's very hard to
disentangle these
because it looks the same.
But what you're saying now is
we can have different versions
of that where you could have
either the computer implement
it, or you could choose for
other people, and so on.
I think that's what
you were saying.
And then from that,
you could say, well,
if you're also rejecting
that, then perhaps it's
not about the procedure per se.
If the computer chose 6 and
4 and you reject it anyway,
then it's not to
do with fairness,
because the computer was
perhaps just randomizing.
But it's rather to
do with, like, I
don't like to have less than
somebody else in the same game.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
So if you used a
computer, you would
be able to [INAUDIBLE] just
disliking [INAUDIBLE] less.
If you have an individual
respond to [INAUDIBLE] accept
or reject an offer that
somebody else made,
it's quite [INAUDIBLE]--
PROFESSOR: Right.
AUDIENCE: Then you would
see whether they were just
trying to punish.
PROFESSOR: I see.
Yes, I see.
I see.
So yes, you can do that.
There's a bit of an
issue, a little bit like--
another version of that would
be just I don't like inequality,
but I just might want to--
I just really like 5-5
or over 50-50 outcomes.
There, I think we can look at
what you were saying earlier,
which is to say I could see
if there's a third party that
looks at somebody
choosing 60 for themselves
and 40 for somebody else,
versus somebody choosing 40
for themselves and
60 for somebody else.
If you really
dislike inequality,
you would just reject
both of those things.
And if you sort of
instead think this
is like-- you
dislike inequality.
If the person only does that for
themselves in some selfish way,
you would only reject the
60-40, but not the 40-60.
Great.
Right.
So the answer is no, we cannot
distinguish these motives based
on the ultimatum game.
So we need some additional
evidence to do that.
We're going to do
that mostly next time.
We're going to try to make
some progress towards that.
Now, if you now think about
the proposer's motive--
if a proposer gives a large
or a small amount, what can
we learn from that?
Or why is it difficult to figure
out what the proposal is doing?
If you see somebody gives
a large amount of money,
what have you learned from that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: It could be that
they're just being optimistic,
or it could be that they
have beliefs about what
the responder would reject
versus what the responder would
not reject.
And they could
reject [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
So it could be that I'm
just trying to be nice.
I'm trying to be friendly.
I care about you.
I offer you a 50-50 because
I want you to have half.
Or it could be that
I just actually
don't care about you at all.
I just think if I
offer you only 30 or 20
or whatever, there's
a good chance
that you might reject it.
Therefore, I just
optimize over my--
so it depends on my
beliefs about what
the rejection rates are.
And if the beliefs are that
below 30% or 40% people's
rejection rates are
positive and sort of higher,
I might essentially just
maximize depending on my risk
preferences or whatever.
Suppose I'm risk-neutral.
I might just maximize
expected payout.
It might be that
essentially 40% or 50%
is just the optimal solution
to that maximization problem,
and I just don't care
about you whatsoever.
So if I'm looking at this
behavior essentially,
if I'm looking at
an ultimatum game
and looking at a proposer
offering large amounts
or positive amounts, you can
learn nothing about their--
or it's very hard
to learn anything
about their social preferences,
because essentially there's
strategic motives
potentially involved as well.
Is that clear?
Or any questions?
So what do we need to do then?
Well, now we need to sort
of have some other evidence.
So we talked about this already.
When you think about
social preferences,
you can think about three broad
categories of preferences.
And we're going to talk
about this a lot more.
So one is distributional
preferences.
This is to say that you
care about outcomes.
You care about how
much each person gets.
So that's to say we can
sort of represent this to,
like, I put some weight on
my utility, on my outcomes.
I put some weight
on your outcomes.
And then depending on
what that weight is,
I'm going to decide about
how to distribute outcomes.
These are sort of
distributional preferences.
Then there are
things like what we
want to call face-saving
concerns, which
is people don't want to
look bad in front of others.
You can also think about
this like social image, which
is to say, I want to
look like I'm a nice guy.
So in particular, if I'm in
public making certain choices,
if I'm being observed,
I'm going to behave
in a very friendly way.
If I could secretly be
mean, I would do that.
But as long as my social
image is at stake,
I might look like a nice person.
We're going to talk about some
experimental evidence looking
at that.
And then there's some
which we want call
intentions-based preferences.
These are things
like reciprocity,
procedural justice, and other
facets of social preferences.
Broadly speaking,
you can think of this
as fairness, which is
to say people don't care
about the outcomes, per se.
They care about essentially
the process in which
the outcomes were generated.
So they might be perfectly
happy with one person getting
a lot and another person
getting nothing as
long as the computer
randomized and [INAUDIBLE],,
the probability of getting money
was the same for everybody.
So that would be
somebody who said--
these would be intention-based
preferences, where people say,
this is procedural justice.
This is a fair thing to do.
And people are
motivated by that,
or essentially, they
might reciprocate.
In cases when they
think things are unfair,
they might not do
so in case they
think things are
fairly generated, even
if things are unequal ex-post.
OK.
So now we're going to talk
about all three of those.
So let's start with
distributional preferences.
This is, again, the simplest
kinds of social preferences.
This is very much
a natural extension
of how economists
think about the world.
This is going back
to Gary Becker,
I think, in the '60s, where
essentially, instead of saying,
does a utility function that
just has my own outcomes,
as my own consumption
as an argument,
instead, have a utility function
that has my own utility,
how much I get, a
function of that,
plus how much does
the other person
get, and a weight on
that other person.
And so again, we
sort of look at,
like, the person cares not
about only how much they get,
but also the other.
There's two versions
of that, and this is
what you were saying earlier.
There are interested
distributional preferences
and disinterested
distributional preferences.
The interested one
is essentially--
the version is, like,
where I'm involved,
and I get a certain
outcome, and there's
another person involved,
and I put some weight
on that other person.
So it's about me
versus another person,
and how these resources
are being divided.
Could be also multiple
people, of course.
And then there's a
disinterested part,
which is to say, how
do I want resources
to be divided across others?
This is questions like, how
do we want society to look?
How do people feel about
inequality and the like?
Or, like what public goods--
how much should the government
engage in redistribution
and so on?
These would be often--
to some degree, of
course, it's interested
because people have to pay
taxes or receive benefits
from the government.
But often, it's you
can ask questions
people have opinions about.
Suppose you live in the US.
You could have opinions about
how should Europe's tax system
look like.
What is fair and what is unfair?
Those would be, essentially,
disinterested distributional
preferences?
Any questions on that?
So we're going to
start with this
and see how far can you get
distributional preferences.
What kinds of things
can be explained?
And then we're going
to move towards saving
face or social image
type of concerns.
So the dictator game, I
already explained to you
what it looks like.
So here's what the dictator
game looked like in class
with no stakes.
This is very typical
to how people
behave in the real world.
What do we see here?
What are patterns of behaviors?
This is no stakes, and it's just
hypothetical questions here.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There are
two large groups.
One group that
doesn't give anything,
and a group that gives half.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
And this is very typical,
again, in many situations.
There's a group
of people, often,
like, 30%, 40% of people
who just essentially keep
the money.
There's a group of
people that thinks
50-50 is the right thing to do.
That's often also something,
like, 30% of people.
And then there's people
often in between,
often between 0 and 50.
And there are some people
who tend to give a lot.
That's often a
minority of people.
Now, what can we infer
from those choices?
What can we infer from
people who choose 0?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: They give
themselves [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: And do we have
any objections to that?
Or what other interpretation
could we have?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: In the case of
money, we can't necessarily
assume they're
self-interested, I guess,
because they could be
giving it to charity.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So in the case of money,
you could keep the money.
You could say, I'm
choosing the $10.
And instead, I'm
giving it to somebody
who is in higher
need, who has higher
marginal value of this money.
That could be you could
give it to charity
or give it to somebody on the
street or any other person
you think is in need.
So that person who looks
like they're fairly selfish
might, in fact, be quite
generous in the sense
of giving the money to others.
That's a common issue
with a lot of these games,
is essentially it's often an
outside option in a sense of,
like, we can look at these games
as if this is the only game.
That's the only thing
that's happening
in the world, and nothing
else, and look at--
try to explain
behavior through that.
But often the issue is
there's other things that
happen in the world.
So when I think
about, am I behind,
or do I get more money
versus somebody else, when
you play with somebody who is
a lot richer or a lot poorer
than you are, in fact, giving
them $10 versus not or $5
or not or will not change
that fact that you're
a lot richer than they are.
So perhaps you should give a
lot more, a lot less money,
and so on.
So in anything that
we're assuming,
we look at this
through the lens of,
like, there's only this game
that happens, and nothing else.
It turns out that's actually
a pretty good approximation.
People sort of, what we
call, are narrowly framed.
They look at
essentially this game
as if this is completely
separate from anything
else in the world.
So people tend to not
integrate these games
with the rest of life
or the rest of utility.
So expected utilities
would say, you
should integrate this
game with everything else
that happens in life.
So you should not look
at, like, 6 versus 4.
I'm earning more
than somebody else.
You should look at, like,
what is my income overall,
a lifetime income?
What is your lifetime income
or the expected lifetime
income of somebody
else in the experiment?
And depending on that, you
should give money or not.
Or differently, you
might say, well,
should I give money to
somebody else in class?
Well, perhaps not because
most people in class
will eventually make a lot
of money once they graduate.
And instead, let's
just use that money
and give it to somebody else
who has higher need of that.
OK.
So here's no stakes.
It turns out when you look
at stakes, not much happens.
So this is answers-- if you
look at-- this is no stakes.
Here's stakes.
Answers look, in
fact, very similar.
There's not much
of a difference.
Even when you have
higher stakes--
I think this is, like,
$20, and the like-- people
seem to behave very similarly.
So it seems to be, in fact,
asking hypothetical questions--
and this is how
some of these games
started, just asking
hypothetically,
what would you do if somebody
gave you $10 and so on?
Turns out, you actually
get pretty good answers
for how people
behave in reality.
That's true for this
class, but that's also
true in actual experiments.
In actual experiments,
if you just ask people,
like, what would you do?
And then when you
actually implement it
with the same people
or with other people,
you get actually pretty
similar patterns across people.
Now, we do find that--
so we had a version of
that that was essentially
in private, which is
to say you did not
have to reveal if selected
to the entire class,
essentially, what you chose,
but only to the other person.
Notice that that's not really
private in the sense of you
still have to tell the other
person, ha, I chose 10,
and you get 0, so
that's not very nice.
There's other versions
that would be in private,
would just be the other
person might never find out,
or the other person might
at least never find out
that it was you who
chose 10, and they got 0.
And so but what we do
see, if you look at--
I think this is with
monetary stakes.
This is with $10.
This is with $10 in private.
And you do see, for
example, that when
you look at the fraction
who gives essentially 100%,
that fraction tends to go down.
So it looks like people are
somewhat less nice in private.
We're going to get
back to that again
in the sense of trying
to see-- when we look
at the question of,
are people really nice
when they give money, and so on.
We're going to look at cleaner
versions of that, where people
have the ability to
essentially hide in some ways
that they're not nice.
How might one do that?
How could you-- what
kind of game would you
design to hide the fact
that the person is not nice?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: For example,
if the recipient
is only given the
money and not told
what percentage of the
original money [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Right.
So one version of that
would be the recipient just
doesn't even know
what the game is.
They just get some money.
Here's some money
for whatever reason.
You were just given it because
you're in the experiment.
And so you could
just essentially hide
the entire game
from the recipient.
What's another
thing you could do
where you don't hide the
entire game but sort of say,
still, there's a game?
But what other ways could you--
in what other ways
could you hide the fact
that people are not nice?
What mechanisms
could you implement?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you mix robots
and [INAUDIBLE] people.
PROFESSOR: Exactly.
And that's exactly--
I'm going to show you that,
I think, on Wednesday.
That's exactly what people
have done, where are you say,
with 50% chance there's a robot
who is not very nice or very
nice or whatever, and
some chance the robot
is really mean, with some
chance the robot is really nice.
And now we can look at--
so with 50%, the robot decides.
With 50% chance, you decide.
And the recipient will
never know whether it
was a robot versus you.
And so now you can essentially
hide behind the robot.
You can say, well, I really
wanted to give you a lot.
But sorry, the robot
was really mean.
Too bad.
And the other person
will never find out.
And it turns out when you
do that kind of game, people
tend to be a lot less nice
than when there's no robot.
OK.
So then we have chocolate.
Looks like people are
giving somewhat more
when it comes to chocolate.
They tend to give a lot more
when it comes to apples.
So now, why is that?
Why does that matter?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you model
algorithms, your utility
plus the other person's
utility [INAUDIBLE],,
it could be that people
with marginal utility,
in chocolate apples decline
more than [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Yes.
It turns out getting the fifth
or sixth or seventh apple
of the day, maybe
not as enjoyable
as the first or second.
So exactly.
So well, it's really
reasonable to think
that the marginal
utility of money
is linear for small amounts.
If I give you $1, 2, or 3,
or 4, or 5, in some sense,
that shouldn't be very concave.
We discussed that at length.
For apples, they're perishable.
There's only so many apples
you can eat on a given day.
So really what we should
look at is, like, what's
the utility of apples?
And if the marginal utility
of apples is decreasing,
that might matter quite a bit.
OK.
So maybe let me
summarize a little bit.
What did we learn in
those kinds of games?
So first is people look fairly
generous in dictator games,
even when the game
is largely private.
We're going to challenge that
assumption a little bit more,
exactly as you suggested,
with other ways in which
either people can be more
private, they can just
hide the game entirely,
or when they perhaps
can hide behind a machine or
a computer or in other ways,
or when they perhaps can opt
out of the game in certain ways.
People generally seem
to give something
like 30% of the total.
That's quite common.
20% to 30% is quite
common overall.
It doesn't seem to matter
that much whether there's
hypothetical versus
actual choices.
The size of the stakes also
seem not to matter that much.
We seem to see somewhat
different behaviors
of chocolates and apples.
There's also some people
who told me that they're
lactose intolerant and so on.
So essentially saying,
like, their marginal utility
of chocolate is quite low.
So it's much easier-- it's
much less costly to give
to somebody else.
Or put differently, it's
actually efficient potentially
because the marginal
utility of chocolate
is much higher for that other
person than it is for you.
Of course, there's a
problem now, again,
that you could just choose
the chocolates for yourself
and then just give
it to your friends.
So you look quite selfish,
but in fact, you might not be.
So anyway, but sort of
what really matters here--
and this is perhaps--
in some sense, when we talk
about apples and chocolates,
it's a little bit silly.
But when you think
about a dictator game
where you play with somebody in
Kenya whose income or lifetime
income is, like, orders of
magnitude lower than yours,
then it matters,
actually, quite a bit
what's the marginal
utility of the $10 that you
could keep for yourself
versus for that person.
For that person,
that's a lot of money.
For you, a lot less.
And so you might
be more generous
when playing with a person
whose marginal utility of money
or consumption is a lot higher.
This is what I was
mentioning as well.
You want to think about,
what is the outside option?
So some people might
give low amount
and decide to give the
money or the apples
or whatever to somebody else.
Those people will look
selfish in dictator games,
while, in fact,
they're quite generous.
That's a problem
with these games
that are hard to deal with.
We're not going to be able
to deal with that overall.
You can think about it a
little bit and sort of see.
Can we give people options
to opt out and so on?
But it will always be an issue.
It's less of an issue than
you perhaps think about it.
Conceptually, that's
a huge problem.
But when we look at
people's actual behavior,
it looks like people really
behave as if this was
the only thing in the world.
And then, in some ways,
it's quite predictive
of actual behavior in the world,
even perhaps, in some ways,
it shouldn't be.
Any other comments or things we
learned perhaps from the game
or that you observed?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is there a possibility
that the people that give 0,
it's just that they're
interested distribution
[INAUDIBLE] is the same
as your disinterested one,
and they actually think, like,
oh, the best thing for society
is for me to have those $10
and not the other person?
PROFESSOR: So because you put
a lot of weight on yourself or?
AUDIENCE: Sort of
like, regardless
if it's correct or
not, but you think
that the way you'll
use these $10
is better for society
than the other person?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I think you
have to justify that somehow
in the sense of,
like, if you are very
similar to the other students,
then you might sort of
think that dividing it--
so depends what do you think is
the marginal utility of money.
So if you think the
marginal utility of money
is essentially the same for
everybody, in some sense then,
it doesn't matter very
much whether you keep it
to yourself versus
somebody else,
in some sense because, in
the grand scheme of things,
it doesn't look very different.
It could be that, for example,
you think, for whatever reason,
you just really had a bad
day, and you can use the $10
to buy something nice.
It could be that you
think you're relatively
poor to others in class.
For whatever reason, you just
don't have a lot of money
right now.
The marginal utility of money
for you might be really high.
So again, and in some sense,
that's socially efficient.
You would actually--
even if it weren't you,
you would give the
money to yourself.
Now, I think it is
the case that when
you look at these
distributions, it
tends to be that 30% of
people keep all of that money.
So it tends to be that it's hard
to believe that that's really--
I mean, you'd have to look at,
like, how does that correlate
with other characteristics?
It probably does,
and we'll get back
to that in the sense
of when we see now,
when people have the chance
to hide money and so on, when
you see now the fraction
of people who choose
$10 for themselves
and 0 for others
goes up, that, in some ways,
compared to when you can't
hide, that perhaps is an
identifying selfishness and so
on.
Here, when you see
people keeping 10,
you can come up with lots
of explanations, including
the one that you mentioned,
but also including the ones you
keep it for yourself and
then give it to your friends
and share it with
them and so on.
And we can't really
infer very much.
But in these
cleaner experiments,
where you can
really say, OK, when
you don't have the
outside option, when
you don't have the chance to
hide, you look quite nice.
That goes away when you
have the chance to hide.
Presumably, that is because
you just are selfish and not
for other reasons.
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Have people
looked at if things
change if you
actually get the money
or get the apples beforehand?
Like, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Surely
they-- surely they have.
What I don't know--
so surely [INAUDIBLE]..
So [INAUDIBLE] is very
robust in various situations.
So my guess is they were
less likely to give.
I don't have--
I can look it up, but I don't
have like a great experiment
that I can tell you about.
But my sense is that--
so the question is, if you give
people the $10 into their hand,
are they going to
choose differently?
My guess is they will
look a lot less selfish.
In the experiment that
you played, in some sense
you are sort of
endowed with a game.
So in some ways--
but you could do
deviation of that.
You could look at,
like, here's $10.
It's neither yours nor
the other person's.
How would you like to divide it?
My guess is that person
will be more generous when
they do that compared to
saying, like, here's $10.
They give it to you in
$1 bills, and now you
have to give me back some.
People will be more likely
to keep the money when
they actually have the money in
hand, when they feel like it's
yours or theirs,
as opposed to have
to divide money that doesn't
really belong to any person.
So my guess is that's
true, but I don't--
there's literally thousands
of experiments of people doing
these kinds of variations.
So I'm sure there is
somebody who has done this.
I can look up and see
whether I find that.
OK.
Any other thoughts
of what we learned?
OK.
So when you now think
about how should you
model these distributional
preferences--
and there's a classic paper
by Charness and Rabin.
Rabin is the guy that you
know from the calibration
theorem about risk preferences.
And the way their
model is very simple.
They essentially
have the preferences
over outcomes x1 and x2.
Think of this as money.
It could be also apples
or something else.
Money is perhaps a
better approximation
because the marginal
utility of money--
think of this as
rather constant.
And now player 2
is the dictator.
So x2 is how much player 2 gets.
So player 2 has a
utility function u2.
The utility of player
2 has a function of x1.
This is how much the
other person gets, and x2,
how much the player 2 gets.
And the utility function
looks like rho times
x1 plus 1 minus rho times x2.
If x2 is larger
or equal than x1--
that is to say that
the person is ahead,
if x2 gets more than x1--
and it's sigma times x1
plus 1 minus sigma x2
if x2 is smaller
or equal than x1.
So what do these
parameters measure?
What a rho and
sigma measure here?
Why might they be different?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How nice they are?
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
What does it do?
How much weight do you put on
yourself or the other person?
AUDIENCE: So if
it's a lower value,
then you don't really care
about the other person,
so you put more
weight on yourself.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So in the extreme case--
I guess, in one case, I
guess, if you choose--
if this is 0, then
essentially, you're
back in the neoclassical case of
not caring about others at all.
So if you choose, like, rho
sigma equals 0, then it's just,
like, how much do you get?
You should get 0, and you
should accept any offer, right?
And now as rho and sigma
goes up, 0.5 or whatever,
you give more weight
on the other person.
So 0.5, for example,
is the case where
you care equally about the other
person and yourself, right?
Because the weights
are then the same.
Now, why might rho and
sigma be different?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So probably
rho is larger than sigma.
PROFESSOR: And why is that?
AUDIENCE: So if you're
person 2 and you already
know you're getting more
than the other person,
then you don't feel such
a need to do so much--
you don't feel a need to
have so much more than them.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
It's just easier.
That seems to be a very
intuitive feature of the world.
It seems to be much
easier to be generous
when you're ahead anyway.
If you're very rich,
you might as well
give some money to the
poorer person, and so on.
If you are poorer
than the other person,
it's much harder to be
generous in some ways,
perhaps because you
feel like you deserve
to get as much as
the other person,
so why would you give
the other person more?
You put essentially less
weight on that other person
if you're behind.
What's the case of
sigma smaller than 0?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Would it
be then the person
who want to hurt
the other person,
so then they put more weight
on decreasing their value?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
So if you're behind-- so it's
the case where you are behind,
you're the x2, the player 2.
If player 2 is behind,
has less than player 1.
Now, you might get
positive utility
from reducing
player 1's outcome.
So if you're
behind, you'd rather
have the other person get
less, and you'll feel better
about that, presumably because
you're then less behind, even
holding constant
your own outcomes.
So if you keep your own
outcome, your own payment,
the same-- suppose you get 5.
The other person gets 20--
you feel better if
the other person
gets 15 or 10 because
you're less behind now
than the other person.
OK, so you're willing to
hurt the other person.
You might be even willing to pay
to hurt the other person, which
is kind of what happens
in the dictator game
when the person rejects
the dictator game.
Any questions on that?
So I have an example of
sigma smaller than 1.
Suppose you have
sigma being minus 1/3.
You have to choose
between 0, 0 and 9, 1.
What are you going to choose?
So this is what this
looks like, sigma times
x1 plus 1 minus sigma x2.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You choose 0, 0.
PROFESSOR: And why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because it
multiplies the other numbers.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Right, so
essentially-- the reason
is that essentially, if
you look at this situation,
and you put minus 1/3
weight, essentially,
on the other person.
So you really don't like
the other person getting 9.
So you're really
unhappy about that.
Despite the fact that you value
getting some money yourself--
you have positive
value on that as well.
It's, I guess, 4/3 times 1.
But sort of putting
together, that's negative.
So essentially, you're
willing to pay--
and this is, I guess, one
explanation potentially
why people might reject.
And this is, I guess,
what I was saying earlier.
You might reject the
ultimatum game simply
for distributional reasons.
You might just say, I don't
like being behind in this game.
If I'm behind, I put negative
weight on this other person,
and then I'm now
rejecting it because I
feel happier if the person who
is in front of me gets less,
even if that comes at the cost
of me having to pay some money.
Now, notice, you are not going
to reject all unequal offers.
So I think 6-4, you
would probably accept.
But you will reject
really uneven offers.
So in some sense, if I ask you
questions using the strategy
method, as we did--
if I asked you questions
about at what threshold
would you reject an
offer, I can essentially--
if I assume that your
preferences look like this,
I can back out,
essentially, your sigma.
Questions on that?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What's the
utility [INAUDIBLE]
for the dictator, not the person
who gets to reject the offer?
PROFESSOR: Sorry,
this is just-- sorry,
I should have been clearer.
So this could be for--
these are preferences that are
generic for any types of games
that are being played.
So you could apply
this to any game.
So Charness and Rabin,
essentially what they do
is-- in their paper,
and it's a long paper
that covers a lot of ground.
But essentially, what
they're saying is,
like, here's what distributional
preferences might look like.
And you can then choose
different parameters.
And then the question is, like,
what kinds of behavior now
can we explain?
Being the dictator
game, potentially you
can try to explain sort
of people's behavior.
But not I'm trying to apply
it to the ultimatum game.
Or you could also apply
it to the trust game
and say, for what
kinds of behavior,
what kinds of preferences might
people do certain behavior?
So what kinds of behaviors
can be explained with that?
So now what's the experimental
evidence on rho and sigma?
Just to remind you,
rho is the parameter,
the weight that you put on the
other person if you're ahead.
Sigma is the parameter on the
other person when you're behind
in a situation.
So we think that when
people are ahead,
most people seem to
have a positive rho.
So people usually tend to--
when ahead, they're willing
to sacrifice some money
to increase the other
person's payout.
So this is essentially-- when
you think about dictator games,
when they have 10,
essentially you
think of this as being,
like, 10-0, you're ahead.
So you're willing to sacrifice
at least some money, like 7-3
or 6-4, even 5-5.
You like that better.
You're happy to give the
other person some amount.
A minority are even
willing to sacrifice money
to give the other person
an equal amount of money
or even less--
sorry, even more.
When deciding to
split $10, subjects
tend to give about
20% to 25% on average.
In class, that was
actually pretty close.
The 28%, I think, are
about the $10 amount.
You guys gave it
something like 28%.
That's actually pretty
close to what people would
do in normal dictator games.
The estimated rho
tends to be about 0.4.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How can rho be
estimated from the dictator
game?
The linearity of the
preferences here,
shouldn't it predict
that player 2 will always
either give 0 or give 50%?
PROFESSOR: No,
it's just to say--
I think this is just to say you
have the same marginal utility
than I have.
So depending on when I ask
you, like, how much do you
give, that pins down your rho.
AUDIENCE: But if
x1 is 10 minus x2,
and we want to maximize rho
x1 plus 1 minus rho times
x2, and you're
maximizing that over x2.
[INAUDIBLE] equation,
shouldn't it be [INAUDIBLE]??
PROFESSOR: No, no, but the
unknown here is the rho.
It's essentially to
say, for example, you
choose 6-4, that means
you prefer 6-4 over 7-3,
and you prefer 6-4 over 5-5.
And those two
inequalities essentially
give you a bound on rho.
We can talk afterwards, but
I'm pretty sure that's true.
Yeah.
But yeah, that's essentially
just saying, like, essentially
what you do is you have--
since you chose
a certain option,
now essentially you'd prefer
not to choose a higher option.
You prefer not to
choose a lower option.
When you write that down,
that should give you
inequalities as a function
of rho in this case.
But we'll talk about
it in two minutes.
What's the experimental
evidence of sigma?
Only about 10% to 20% of
players have sigma strong enough
to pay a non-trivial amount
to hurt the other player.
These are people essentially
who reject offers.
About 30% of people
will sacrifice
to help a player ahead of them.
So even if they're behind
and have the option of, like,
can you sort of help the person
in front of you, 30% of people
will do that.
If a person is behind
you, often neither
wants to help or hurt
the other person by much.
Essentially, sort of
like, whatever, I don't
care about this other person.
I don't feel inclined
to do very much.
But also, I'm not
necessarily hurting them.
And now I want to
just preview what
we're going to talk
about next time, which
is to say it looks
like people are pretty
nice in various situations.
It looks like in the dictator
game, they give money.
It looks like in
the ultimatum game,
they give money, and so on.
Looks like people
give money to charity.
This is what we discussed
earlier about 2% of GDP.
People also do a bunch
of volunteering or other
contributions.
So they give some time, about
15 hours per month on average
when you do surveys.
So it looks like people seem
fairly generous overall.
Now, when you think about social
recognition or social image,
perhaps that picture
gets less rosy overall.
It seems to be that
essentially, people
care a lot about what others
think of them, and not just
about the outcomes, per se.
So one example would be
gifts to organizations.
If you look at
thresholds of-- like,
when you look at the
Boston Symphony Orchestra,
and you look at the
distribution of people giving,
it tends to be there's
these thresholds where
you can give a certain amount,
and then you recognize them.
Like, when you go to the Boston
Symphony, in this booklet,
you can who's like a certain
donor of which category.
People tend to bunch
just above the thresholds
for these categories.
And presumably, that's because
they want to look good.
That's just one example.
So I think the next question
we're going to ask on Wednesday
is to say, is social recognition
a major motivation for giving?
So people seem to not only
care about what others get,
but what others think of
them when they give or not.
So in some ways, that's a
philosophical discussion
in saying, like, are people
really nice versus not?
And you might say, it's
sort of disappointing
if they're not nice in certain
situations compared to others.
The flip side of
that is, well, if you
know what kinds of
situations generate
altruistic or prosocial
behavior, well,
if you know that, then you
can essentially also create
situations to
foster prosociality.
So once we kind of know
under which structure
or in which kind
of circumstances
people are nice,
well, that gives us
some lever or some ways for
policy and saying, like,
well, you have to
design your institutions
or your organizations or
your company in certain ways
to get people to behave
nice to each other.
In contrast, if
you thought people
are either generally nice or
not, well, then in some sense,
that's good to know.
But then in some sense, we
can't do very much about that.
And that's what we're going
to talk about next time.
Thank you.